fueron 15 meses de negociaciones unas
negociaciones que fueron mediadas por
Estados Unidos pero finalmente hoy tanto
el Primer Ministro israelí y Jair lapiz
como el presidente libaneses aún dijeron
que todas sus necesidades y demandas
Fueron satisfechas por el último
borrador entregado por Estados Unidos
El último obstáculo que debió sortear
esta negociación fueron dos pedidos de
enmiendas que había presentado Líbano a
un primer borrador y que Israel Israel
había rechazado estas estos demandó que
durante el fin de semana intensas en
negociaciones se fueran necesarias para
saldar estos obstáculos estuvo cerca de
caer el acuerdo por estas demandas pero
finalmente esto no ocurrió el límite
para la firma del acuerdo es el próximo
31 de octubre que es cuando vence el
mandato de aún y lo que viene ahora es
que ambos gobiernos se realizarán
consultas puertas adentro para conseguir
la ratificación final de cada gobierno
del lado israelí se enfrenta también a
cuestionamientos de la posición el pacto
va a ser presentado ante el parlamento
israelí que puede realizar observaciones
Aunque el gobierno No necesariamente
tiene que hacer caso a ellas y también
enfrenta un costado judicial porque hay
se han presentado demandas ante el
tribunal supremo israelí sobre si un
gobierno interino está en capacidad de
firmar un acuerdo de esta de este este
tipo de acuerdo por el lado de la
oposición el líder Benjamín en tamiacu a
rechazado el acuerdo y ha dicho que si
él vuelve a ser el Primer Ministro no lo
pondrá en práctica digamos eso en el
marco jurídico pero ahora fue hablemos
desde el terreno la importancia de esta
frontera marítima porque es tan rico
esta parte del mar Mediterráneo
son 860 kilómetros que están en disputa
desde hace larga Data y que cubren los
campos de gases de Cádiz y Cana el
primero va a ser explotado por Israel si
este acuerdo prospera y el segundo por
Líbano es un acuerdo histórico porque
Israel Líbano no no tienen relaciones
formales ni límites reconocidos y están
formalmente en guerra decíamos Esta
última ronda de negociaciones demandó 15
meses de conversaciones y habían había
llega a un éxito después de que otras
tres administraciones estadounidenses
también intentaran llegar a un acuerdo
al Líbano le daría la posibilidad de
explotar a gas lo cual le permitiría
encontrar una salida a su crisis
energética y también a su crisis
financiera de allí que el Gobierno ya
haya alcanzado un acuerdo con la
compañía francesa total para comenzar la
exploración de las aguas mientras que
Israel por su parte habilitó a la firma
británico griega energian para que
comience las pruebas en el gasoducto de
caricia